[Music]
so quite fergie just set this up before
we hit play i'm gonna take a dab here
real quick uh i i don't really know what
more to say about this other than it's
two people uh you know
furries two people no not furries two
people uh
you know
tying the knot
[ __ ] uh i don't like i don't know
putting that whole ball and chain on
them ankles and [ __ ] you know
settling down trying to start you know
just you know the average american
family you know like pick a fence two
kids a dog
can i guess
can i guess super duper that's not what
i'm talking about
can i guess something here sure if i
will
is one of them gonna throw like a
pokeball at the other saying i caught
you
it's oh no i didn't think about that no
is that does that really happen it's so
much worse than anything that you could
say
okay okay boys and girls
um what we're about to watch is
i can't believe i'm saying this in real
life this is good this is a real thing
everyone everyone get in
we're about to watch a pokemon wedding
i don't
why
[Music]
because god is dead and we killed him no
what is bojack horseman doing in there
whoa that's hil no no no that's that's
ethan klein's wife
okay yeah i'm sorry
[Music]
all right then
also really quick oh my god really quick
bojack horseman isn't as deep as you
think it is you're just you're just your
dad left
courtney actually yeah they are alex
play mom
oh my
oh my god
so so in case you're wondering and you
haven't caught up i'm not so
so i'm not wondering the bride and groom
here
are using are using their groomsmen and
their bridesmaids as their pokemon and
they're having a battle
oh yeah
is that what's happening vergie
also with with what these people look
like i'm not i'm not surprised
it looks her back looks like a bag of
idaho potatoes
oh that's a snorlax royce this couple ah
it's a horlacks
all right so have you guys ever played
like one sims town for like a while and
then like you just check on the
neighbors and all of a sudden your
neighbor's like married to some weird
random sim that came out of nowhere
uh-huh yes
that's that's this okay so
quick question is frozen that asian guy
back there is that you no okay since
it's not you is that the one the tv fell
on because that's the only reason this
person should be at this wedding that's
prob that's probably it okay
[Music]
this has
way less views than it should guys
this this should be
this should have more views than gangnam
style okay
i applaud you because
i i usually find these cringe [ __ ]
but this one is so bad
that my neck is starting to stiff up
from all the cringe
i didn't find this one personally i i
[ __ ] pulled it out of ap's discord
because okay i used it but uh i i do
that's fine
that's fine
ap steals myself all the time so i don't
care yeah dude he steals all your [ __ ]
[ __ ] steals mine too
stole my bell thing piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and pedro we all know pedro is just
we all know pedro is just him making fun
of me
um
pablo you don't even watch a show
[Laughter]
how do you steal so many of his bits and
you don't even watch it can you tell
people in my comments that
sorry um
anyway pokemon wedding
[Music]
bro you can't do this to me bro come on
man what the [ __ ] you virgin [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off that one
what is that on her back a shell she's a
squirtle because she squirts
i don't want to see that
did you know that a lot of secrets not a
lot of people don't know this but
squirtles just pee
[Laughter]
yeah you made a [ __ ] squirtle but you
ever made her blastoise
oh [ __ ]
that was one of the cringiest things
i've ever said by ah oh it was
what is this
hey
hey i know you guys are having trouble
hearing it but they're playing the
battle theme over this i'm not having
trouble
hey vergie vergie vergie i hear it just
fine
i know you're worried that i didn't i
hear it just fine i just want you to
appreciate it
bro
trans andre the giant cosplaying as
jason mraz is the weirdest thing i've
ever seen
hands on jay's a giant dude look at how
she's
she's [ __ ]
she's built like someone with a thyroid
problem now look at her groove
i know i do not i do not want who she
grooming she looks like someone she
definitely looks like someone like the
groom's people trust me
i think i've seen her i think i've seen
her lips of tick tock video
oh my god it's so funny
she looks like a [ __ ] horse standing
on a tiny legs
[Laughter]
[Music]
show them how happy you are and that's
actually you know that this is from 2016
this video i just looked it up so that
guy there that's actually uh bobby lee
he went there with his ex at the time
kalila
um but it's actually team red rocket on
the count of her jerking off dogs
[Music]
why is matt walsh there
[Music]
what the [ __ ] bro
[Music]
okay look at the girl okay thank you bro
i was just about i was just about i'm
didn't
that's exactly
that's exactly what i was
th this is
[Music]
you know that somebody who was the
girlfriend of somebody who knew them
right like i mean i could only assume
imagine okay going to weddings already
[ __ ] sucks right
imagine going to this one oh actually no
i'd go to this nah you're right better
you take it back rice
rice
that's either the wife or the the
girlfriend of the groom or bride's
brother i have an idea
i show up to the wedding
wearing this
oh god
and i call myself like a mammy mom or
some sort of you know black pokemon i
don't know what black pokemons are
called oh the digimons
jinx
will burst into flames
oh that's not nice
no what is this
perch what is this
[Music]
let's kill it with fire all of it
virgie why are you muted explain
yourself and why you brought this i just
took a [ __ ] giant bar grip and it
[ __ ] murdered me i wish your bong was
a gun
and i wish it murdered you
there are days i wish mine was too yeah
hey look at that guys the only thing
keeping us alive at this point is that
we're not these people
yeah
that [ __ ] want to be in a room with
jack black and [ __ ] whoever the [ __ ]
that guy is next to him i wouldn't want
to be in the room with jack black and
jack white
[Music]
it looks like you should [ __ ] have a
real wedding and not whatever this is
you don't deserve to be married
[Music]
let's hold on a second yes look at the
ass on the on the chick next to the
woman i know what you're terrible i knew
you were gonna say that
and i agree
i actually agree thick you always evenly
match i think you all will make a great
team
imagine being the parents to this thing
oh i have a feeling i have a feeling i
have a feeling those parents haven't
been around her for a while
tag team created
[Music]
so whose dad hasn't been around
okay never mind
never mind not only did they sanction
this [ __ ] they encouraged it who's going
home with the humpback over there
what do you mean the one in the the red
funny you knew which one i was talking
about right
sir that's the bride that's the bride no
that's the bride that's the bride that's
the bride jj walked away for a minute
you see the little fella in the team
rocket
yeah that's that's that's the groom
there they are
[Laughter]
no i don't i don't think you know what
i'm thinking no
he climbs her like a sequoia tree
doesn't involve ropes and pulleys
because that's what i think
they would take they [ __ ] like the ps2
game shadow of the colossus yeah [ __ ]
seriously
it's like
trying to [ __ ] a blue whale
it's like a it's like a remora fish on a
whale shark
just he's just along for the ride
fat [ __ ] uses smother it's very
effective
and that's a guy we're sure of it
sort of apparently and the one on the
left too
[Laughter]
i thought that was her tampon
oh
probably boy or girl i mean also yes
oh my god they're asking are you a boy
or girl i want to hear the genders hold
on oh this might be four thousand
[Music]
okay i i would have gotten up and walked
and now i'm just noticing out of all of
that now i'm noticing the horse head
person oh oh yeah but not see that
before he's probably been here the whole
time he's the only person who is giving
this the exact amount of dignity it
deserves yeah i don't want to show my
face there either he goes oh so they're
having a pokemon wedding i guess to
bring my [ __ ] horse hat yeah exactly
honey honey i need you to go to my
friend's pokemon wedding yeah okay cool
but i'm not gonna care
you cannot make me take it seriously i
will not
be a fun prank
what's that be at the sweating so you're
like let's see let's say we're all there
right
[Music]
i would walk up to one of these people
and be like hey make you do me a favor
my buddy frozen over there he really
doesn't understand like pokemon can you
go explain it to him
and then you go up to another person and
you go hey like i asked homie over there
a second ago to explain pokemon to my
friend frozen but like i don't really
think he's doing a good job could you go
over there and help him
both of you and you see how many you can
get to walk over there and corner frozen
and tell them
uses annoy on frozen it's super
effective
to her
why is it not sam there
the [ __ ] cast of characters here is
amazing this is this is the best wedding
ever
also uh rice
are you able to shrink down uh ellen
over there and put it over the
small suited boy over there
no no the other one the groom oh the
groom sorry
there you go
okay i i don't see you
[Music]
god damn it
now i have to track her you both promise
to tag in when your opponent is in the
ring
that's not easy it's not easy
this isn't easy i can't get a target
lock i can't get a target locked i'm
sorry i can't get a target lock i can't
get a target lock
i got it
okay bye
stay lo she gets to stay little now
yo what up dog
[Music]
is this where the aaa meeting is
[Music]
i quit
i couldn't no i quit you're banished
from bringing things
okay
no
no [ __ ] more
no you just show up and laugh that's all
you do what i'm done
i'm out of here
bye don't have to come
yeah you have a point here
hold on oh yeah this i think by the way
you want to talk about what this
respect this video deserves this is
exactly respect this video deserves
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
i should be there
[Music]
she has a bouquet
it's super good
[Laughter]
you're my best friend
i i don't know bro this should have been
like
how did tosh not cover this
like this is this is up there right like
i'm looking at the views there's like
150 000 but from a video for 2016 like
that's not a lot you know
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
i hate this
oh
you know every once in a while i see
something on the internet and it reminds
me why i'm here
this is why this is one of those times
this is this is what this is the [ __ ] i
live for man i showed everything keeping
me going i showed up with two bad knees
and a dream to make fun of idiots on the
internet and thank god that dream came
true
[Laughter]
but it takes more than singing to make
[Music]
ew no
oh this gets worse
first you what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you vergie
again i ask why is there a woman
groomsman
because
i hate this
why is why is any of this right about
any point i hate this i hate this i hate
this i hate this i hate it it's the
[ __ ] worst thing ever i'm about to
send you chrissy parfait nudes just so
you know if you don't know who chrissy
parfait is you go you about to learn kf
just says it's like a russian doll of
awfulness
okay
rocky take off at the speed of light
surrender now or prepare
no
oh god that's your people come get your
boy frozen come get your boy
royce there's a lot of white people
there too i'm not white either so could
you all you come get your boys
i don't care what race you are did they
high five
yes they high-fived
they [ __ ]
you right i'm sorry i'm sorry you didn't
high five on your wedding
no
that's weird well what i think this is
oh i think this is the courthouse dude
[ __ ] for only charging us twenty
dollars instead of the twenty-five and
then we left the government oh no virgie
virgi i know i think i know what this is
look where they're located i think this
is
i think this is an anime convention
and this is a fake wedding wait no no no
this is a real wedding this is a real
wedding i don't think this might be an
anime convention but this is a real
wedding
yeah i know that's a real wedding
okay
jesus christ
what a killer's row this is huh
what a [ __ ] i mean this is
nice top hat
looks like someone's gonna get a little
shell
tonight god
damn it
who's the wedding singer she's
horrible bro everything in this [ __ ]
freeze frame is awesome dude what's up
with the like 13 year old kid dancing
with that 35 year old woman by the way
that kid that kid 47.
[Music]
don't burn him dressed up as ash ketchum
[Laughter]
he looks like he's about to catch hpv
[Music]
everyone there's awesome everyone there
is awesome
look at that dude right there he's just
see the one in the back right here the
guy next to the guy next to chaz bono
yes
yeah he's here
yeah i see him
he finds this all entertaining but not
for the reasons that everyone else in
that room thinks it is
i know
that's a really good point that's a guy
who's like this is awesome
that's what i would be doing if you
caught me in this video you would never
catch me not smiling
whenever you want to punish him okay
fair enough we'll do that one oh we'll
do that next okay oh i said i sent you
another one royce oh my god you sent me
too many oh no no no no no no no no no
okay okay so the top one is just a
collection of them and can't wait for
tomorrow okay i did that i did that on
[ __ ] my show
i don't like 20 people seen it because
[ __ ] i [ __ ] my whole stream up but
uh
dude every single [ __ ] wedding in
that that that first video i sent you is
[ __ ] horrendous
[Music]
[Laughter]
death by snoozneew
[Music]
she's built like a stand-up base
[Music]
[Music]
she looks like the lead singer the blues
travelers
[Music]
at least she doesn't need to have
children because she could just baby him
hey guys
guys
yeah the cake
i know guys
no i get it guys
guys
the cake
is a pokeball
because god abandoned us
so very long ago and
and honestly
you think there's a pikachu in the in
the cake
i hope there's [ __ ] arsenic in the
cake it's what i [ __ ] hope is in the
cake no
oh god they're feeding it too ah god i
hope the cake is made with the same
stevia from breaking bad
[Music]
is she baby birdoing him
yes
thank you for catching it that was a
good one i'm proud of it
[Music]
oh this gets better doesn't it oh [ __ ]
hold on hold on i got something for this
one actually
okay here we go let's see if this works
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but
he did
you're married the song doesn't work now
that was what was the point
what was the point any of this
you look ridiculous frozen
i still say i have to say the uh fat ass
to highways
catching that whole room
right i think you might be right
[Applause]
[Music]
okay now they're going to have a pokemon
wedding
why is bob's burger here doing this [ __ ]
there's not gonna be the next one it's
not a they're more bayonetta fans it'll
be a banana wedding oh god
[ __ ] bayonetta
[ __ ] yeah i'm going deep i'm going
deep with my references today
what is it just gonna come around with
[ __ ] wheels on it bayonet is great
you want a game that would be way better
on anything but nintendo but we're going
to put it on nintendo bayonetta
okay
that didn't sound um
[Music]
too confident yeah
[Applause]
oh royce uh
pause there and then play money shot i'm
gonna go show links i'm gonna go kill
myself no no no no rather kill myself
let me just kill myself instead
please please just let me let me kill
myself please
god damn it
so the ring is going to be in that poke
ball a little bit
[Music]
see it make you feel better right took
me by the hand
made me a man
that one night one night you made
everything all right
[Music]
this is the greatest video in the
history of the internet in my opinion
honestly this is so good
it's got everything
not the ending i would like but yes
you remember the great white video
yeah
the nightclub
yeah okay that's all